Prof: This course has a
long history.
And the purpose is really to
wonder with you about the
potential effectiveness of
environmental law.
And I really want you to
imagine that we have no
environmental law.
By the end of the course,
I may ask you on a final exam
to design a new system of
environmental law that would
protect us against the problems
that I'm going to run through
with you.
This is an unusual course in
that most law courses do not go
through case histories the way
that we will here.
So that we will be reviewing
perhaps twelve or fourteen
different case histories of
specific problems.
We'll be taking a look at the
statutes that evolved in an
attempt to manage those
problems.
And I will give you my
impressions about how
effectiveness might be judged,
how efficiency might be judged.
And also really answer the
basic question,
which is what's worked,
what has not,
and why, as a way of thinking
about how we're going to respond
to a very new world in which you
will face,
your children will face,
your grandkids will face
approximately ten to twelve
billion people creating more
demand on resources,
more pollution,
rising rates of consumption,
rising rates of waste.
How are we going to manage
these types of problems?
That's really the essential
purpose of the course.
You'll see on the syllabus that
I want to run through quickly
with you that today I'll give
you an overview of the material
that we'll cover over the next
several months.
On Thursday,
we'll review principles and
strategies in environmental law
and I'll give you a quick Cook's
tour of a variety of different
statutes,
as well as the decision
standards that are embedded in
those statutes.
Then we will take a look over
several weeks at the problem of
national security and the
environment,
and really what happens when
the military spends trillions of
dollars per year in the world,
what happens to environmental
quality?
The public sector has not been
the target of twentieth century
environmental law,
but it has been a very
important force in shaping the
environment that we now are
coping with.
We'll look at nuclear
experimentation.
And I've come to believe that
the atmospheric weapons testing
program of the 1940s and 1950s
really demonstrates one of the
greatest success stories that we
have in environmental law,
following the recognition that
the radionuclides that were
created and blown into the
atmosphere,
worked their way into the
stratosphere,
they encircled the globe.
And when they intersected rain
clouds, they would fall to
earth.
They contaminated the soil,
they contaminated the water
supplies.
They contaminated also food
supplies, agricultural crops,
and made their way to the
dinner tables of everybody on
the earth.
The radionuclides eventually
became embedded in human tissue.
Depending on the nuclide,
it would vary between bone or
fat tissue, perhaps the liver,
and pose very well-known
threats.
So we'll review that story,
because there are really
fundamental lessons of ecology,
fundamental lessons of
environmental health that we've
really forgotten.
We've forgotten as we've
attempted to manage air,
water, food,
as well as consumer product
safety or large tracts of lands.
So why have these lessons that
were very clear by 1963,
why have we forgotten those
lessons?
That is the purpose of that
segment.
And for each of these case
histories,
I'll be reviewing the specific
statutes that applied at the
time and talk about how they
evolved and give you a sense of
how you would evaluate whether
or not they've worked,
how effective they were.
We'll take a look too at
preparation for warfare.
It's not only the waging of war
that creates great environmental
destruction;
it's also the preparation for
warfare, the training,
the production of weapons,
the enrichment of uranium.
So that if you look at the 25
to 30,000 different military
bases and installations around
the world, you'll see extremely
severe contamination.
So thinking about how that
should be managed,
how it might be prevented,
will also be the subject of
several lectures,
as well as site restoration.
So we'll be looking at
predominately public sector
issues in this first segment of
the course.
And then we'll take a look at
the private sector,
which has been the target of
most twentieth century
environmental law.
We'll take a look at global
markets and the challenge that
they pose in managing chemicals.
And the management of chemicals
is a very tricky business in
that it demands a high degree of
sensitivity about where
chemicals are released to the
environment.
Where do they go?
How do they move?
Are they persistent?
Where do they end up?
And how are people exposed?
Calculating the magnitude of
exposure is really fundamental
to understanding what the risk
is.
And most environmental laws are
structured to manage chemicals
based on this idea of risk.
So to understand the risk and
to manage it,
you have to understand all of
these intermediate issues,
such as where was it released?
Where does it go?
How does it get into your
environment?
And what are the likely health
effects?
And the word likely is very
important, because it implies
that we need to be thinking
probabilistically.
What's the probability of
damage occurring down the road,
whether or not it's ecological
or human health related?
So we'll be thinking about the
different forms of law that have
evolved to try to deal with this
kind of a problem.
Some set risk-only standards,
some are risk-benefit
balancing, some are cost-benefit
balancing and more utilitarian
in their structure.
So what is the right standard
to apply for very specific
problems?
We will then take a look at a
variety of issue areas,
including what I think of as
industrial agriculture.
The majority of our food is
highly processed.
It is chemically dependent,
particularly on fertilizers and
pesticides and preservatives and
dyes of different sorts.
So what does that mean?
The food packaging industry is
increasingly of interest to me
in my own research.
So I'll share with you several
ideas about how plastics make
their way into your life.
Right now, the synthetic
chemical industry is dominated
by the plastics industry;
it constitutes seventy percent
of the synthetic chemical
industry in the United States.
And each year,
one hundred billion pounds of
chemicals are produced and
released to the environment.
And among all plastics,
among those one hundred billion
pounds, only five percent are
recyclable.
So we are building up a waste
stream that is coming back to
haunt us.
If I took tissue samples from
each of you,
probably ninety-five percent of
you would have residues
phthalates or Bisphenol A,
which are plasticizers in your
body.
And scientists,
including Hugh Taylor right
here at the Yale Medical School,
is now recognizing that these
are very effective chemicals at
exceptionally low doses,
part per trillion doses,
in sending a signal to cells
that estrogen has arrived or
another hormone has arrived.
So that they are triggers of
hormonal activity in many
different species of animals as
well as humans.
So what does this mean?
In one way, it means that we're
conducting quite a chemical
experiment on ourselves,
but also on future generations.
So what should we be doing
about it?
How should we be managing the
chemical universe?
This chemical universe,
by the way, in international
commerce includes about 80,000
different compounds at present.
Two to three thousand new
chemicals are produced and
released to the environment each
year.
And they take many different
forms, pharmaceuticals,
plasticizers,
different metal compounds in
millions and millions of
different products.
So that these chemicals have no
mechanism in law,
even in the United States,
to test what their effect is
and what the risk might be to
either environmental quality or
to human health.
So what should we do about
problems like that?
We'll take a look at air
quality law, and particularly
the concentration of the Clean
Air Act on really very few
chemicals.
There are six chemicals that
became a target of national air
quality law and regulation.
This is administered by the
Environmental Protection Agency,
and they decide which chemicals
will appear on their radar
screen.
They decide what monitoring
programs are necessary in order
to detect where they go,
how they move,
how they behave in the
environment and how dangerous
they are,
who might be at risk.
One good example of that might
be diesel exhaust.
And you may know that the older
trucks, the less efficient
diesel vehicles,
tend to spew large particulate
matter from their tailpipes.
And these larger particulates,
ten microns in size and larger,
are visible.
It's one of the chemical
threats that is visible.
It's one of the easier ones to
identify.
In fact, with diesel exhaust,
you cannot only see it,
you can taste it,
you can feel it burning in the
back of your throat.
So most people understand when
they are exposed to diesel
exhaust.
Well, one of the interesting
intents of the EPA was to reduce
the particle size,
to reduce the larger particles.
And what happened when the
engines became more efficient to
accomplish that was they
produced more,
but smaller particles.
So the finer particles,
less than one micron in size,
not thinking that these finer
particles can be more deeply
inhaled into the lung,
they reside there,
they get stuck to the sides of
the airways,
particularly in those that have
background illnesses such as
asthma,
emphysema, lung cancer.
So that these particles don't
get expired, so that exposure
becomes more persistent.
The danger to health is
increasing.
There's an interesting
correlation,
and I'm not saying that it's a
causal relationship,
an interesting correlation
between the increasing number of
these finer particles with
rising rates of respiratory
illness in the United States and
in different parts of the
industrialized world.
So why might that be?
Well, let me give you one
analogy.
If you thought about an
aquarium and you fill that
aquarium up, regardless of its
size, with softballs.
And then you calculated the
surface area of those softballs.
And then you took the softballs
out and you filled the aquarium
up with, say,
peas.
And you calculated the surface
area of the peas,
being analogous to the finer
particle size.
You'd find a many-fold increase
in the surface area of the peas
than you would of the softballs.
And because the carbon
particles that are these core
elements of particulates,
because they're sticky,
they tend to lock onto a
variety of different organic
compounds called volatile
organic compounds,
which are also regulated by EPA.
So that the carbon core becomes
the vehicle for bringing a whole
array of different chemicals
into your lung,
very, very fine particles in
size.
So that many times,
the absence of excellent
scientific information can lead
the government into making
decisions that are actually not
health protective or
environmentally protective.
So we need to be very conscious
about the importance of doing
excellent science,
not just science about where
chemicals move in the
environment,
but their effects on human
health.
If you went to EPA's website
and you looked for the purpose
of the Environmental Protection
Agency,
the number one purpose that you
see on their website is to
protect human health from
dangerous elements in the
environment.
That's kind of curious.
Many people think of the
environment as not being that
closely associated with human
health.
We'll look at food safety
issues, and we'll look at the
rise of the organic food
industry,
which I believe is a very
important success story in the
twentieth century,
particularly the result of the
Food Production Act of 1990,
although there was a delay in
adopting standards for organic
foods until the year 2000.
But the organic sector in the
food market now is the largest
growing of any other sector
besides bottled water,
if you include water in the
food industry.
This is very interesting.
So the idea of certification,
of government-sponsored
certification as potentially
creating new markets for
products that are health
friendly or environmentally
friendly.
We'll look at the strengths and
weaknesses of the certification
scheme,
not just related to food,
but also to paper and forest
products and a variety of other
areas,
especially related to buildings.
We'll take a look at the
history of tobacco regulation.
And there's a special legal
paradigm that applies to
tobacco.
But again, it's one of these
types of threats to human health
and environmental quality that
was really very lightly treated,
very lightly regulated during
the twentieth century,
and only now are we seeing the
Food and Drug Administration
being empowered to take tighter
control over the way that
products are marketed.
We'll take a look at the
advertising strategies of
tobacco companies and see a
variety of similarities to other
products,
such as toys or candy or
different kinds of foods toward
children.
So that hooking children early
on to try to cultivate their
taste toward foods that are high
in salt and sugar and fat,
there are some very interesting
similarities there between the
way the tobacco industry was
very anxious to encourage the
youngest in society to try
tobacco products,
knowing that exposures for very
short periods of time could
become addictive.
We'll take a look after spring
break at land use issues.
We'll switch from chemical
problems and pollution problems
to land use issues.
And we'll be particularly
interested in legal strategies
for conservation,
different approaches to set
aside lands to protect
biological diversity,
to protect watersheds in an
effort to improve environmental
quality.
We'll look also at wilderness
and national park law and a
variety of other statutes that
apply to the U.S.
National Forest lands,
the Bureau of Land Management.
And we'll also look at
conflicts between land use and
development and the important
value that we hold for private
property rights in our society.
We'll also think about urbanism
and sprawl and different
smart-growth techniques to try
to control the rate of
development in suburban areas.
We'll also look at the idea of
environmental justice,
which really grows from a
recognition of different groups,
different areas receiving or
being exposed at a higher level
to either chemicals or different
kinds of environmental insults.
So that we'll run through a
variety of cases where groups
claim that they are more
exposed,
more at risk than others,
they're bearing a
disproportionate burden of harm
or threat.
We'll also look at the rising
interest and rising
incorporation of LEED
certification into U.S.,
national, and state law.
So buildings are certified now
to be green at different levels.
The School of Forestry and
Environmental Studies building,
the new Kroon building,
for example,
is applying for the highest
level of LEED certification,
it's called Platinum.
So we'll look at the evolution
of that certification scheme and
I'll be actually quite critical
of the scheme and the way that
standards are being adopted by
different governments that
become the foundation for the
allocation of property tax
breaks,
but also direct subsidies from
both the federal government and
state governments.
We'll take a look then near the
end of the term at the past and
future of nuclear power and the
statutes and regulations that
surround nuclear power,
particularly the statutes that
provided really large subsidies
when compared to subsidies
allocated to renewable energy
sources.
We'll take a look at a variety
of different emissions trading
schemes,
and renewable energy policies,
and then end the course with a
reflection across these
different cases about what we've
learned.
So that's the game plan.
And I wanted to spend just a
couple minutes talking about
course requirements.
The course is structured to
have a final examination worth
forty percent of your grade.
But also, there is a paper or
midterm option that would
constitute fifty percent of your
grade.
And then a discussion section
will be held each week for fifty
minutes.
So everybody will need to sign
up for a discussion section,
and that would be worth ten
percent of your grade.
I'll talk more as we move
through the term about the term
paper option.
There are four books that have
been ordered and I believe are
all in.
There's one that was shipped
yesterday and should be in this
afternoon.
David Kessler's A Question
of Intent,
which provides a really
wonderful review of the history
of tobacco law and regulation.
Michael Pollan,
The Omnivore's Dilemma.
A good part of my career has
been spent thinking about food
quality and food safety,
so we'll take a look at
Pollan's work.
We'll read also a book that I
published just a few months ago
called Green Intelligence
that will run through a variety
of these cases that we'll
examine during the class.
And then we will take a look at
Weinberg and Reilly's book
called Understanding
Environmental Law.
Course themes that I intend to
draw through these cases include
those that are on the back of
page two, or the bottom of page
two.
How is law related to science
and uncertainty?
What causes environmental
damage and health loss?
Where should the burden of
proof of causality lie?
On the public sector or on the
private sector?
On the individual?
So that understanding the idea
of burden of proof is a
fundamental aspect of
understanding environmental law.
We'll also take a look at the
importance of secrecy and the
control over information or
knowledge.
So I think of this as being
really an analogy between the
public sector and the private
sector.
In the private sector,
secrecy is a very important
component in that trade secrecy
protects a company's
understanding of product
ingredients or perhaps how it's
processed or produced or
shipped.
Whereas classified information
in the public sector protects
sensitive information.
In both cases,
the idea is to protect
competitive advantage,
either in international affairs
or in the marketplace.
So we'll see how that plays out
in many of these cases.
We'll also think about the
principle of democracy and how
participation rights vary
depending upon which law we're
looking at.
And as participation rights
expand, decision-making becomes
more complicated.
And what that means is that it
often slows down and it's harder
to reach a mission of improved
environmental quality.
We'll look at property rights.
And rights in law are an
essential component,
but also obligations are an
essential component.
So when I think about law,
I think about how rights are
specified,
how obligations are specified,
and what are the sanctions
applied for deviance,
and where does the perception
of legitimacy for that law come
from?
So we'll be asking those set of
questions for each of the laws
that we review.
We'll take a look too at the
principles of equality and
justice and spend a lot of
attention looking at
disproportionate allocation of
burdens or damages or pollution,
where dangerous facilities are
located.
We'll also take a look at the
idea of risk and precaution.
So what is acceptable risk?
Once it's calculated,
how do you determine what is
acceptable?
If you look across the laws,
the different statutes have
very different definitions of
what acceptable risk is.
We'll also think a lot about
the idea of precautionary law,
as opposed to utilitarian law.
So law that builds in safety
margins or buffer zones to
protect against miscalculations
of risk.
We did not do that when we
built nuclear power plants,
and we've had several severe
accidents in the world,
most notably Chernobyl that
we'll take a look at when we
look at the nuclear power plant
case.
So that thinking about when
should the government be allowed
to balance risks or costs
against benefits,
and when should a fixed
standard of allowable risk drive
a decision?
Those are very difficult
questions.
So that said,
I'd like to just briefly run
through a set of slides here
that I think are reflective of
the material that we'll be
reviewing.
And I wanted to start with this
set of images from Thomas Cole,
a well-known landscape artist
from the nineteenth century,
one of the Hudson River School
painters.
Just to give you a sense of
where I came from,
my background as an
undergraduate was in history.
I had a fascination for English
literature,
but also the history of art,
but a very specialized form of
art,
which was nineteenth and early
twentieth century landscape art.
And I was always fascinated by
this series called The Course
of Empire by Thomas Cole.
In the very first painting on
the lower left,
you see what's thought of as
the savage state.
And this is Thomas Cole's
obvious interpretation of the
evolution of civilization.
So the savage state is wild,
it's hostile.
I think of it in a way as being
wild lands, and I've always had
a strong fascination for wild
lands.
When I was a child,
my dad always took me camping
or hiking up in the White
Mountains in New Hampshire or
the Adirondacks or up in
Vermont.
They really caused me to have
not just a fascination with it,
but also a love of it.
Thinking about how society
might move from the savage or
the wild state to the pastoral
or the Arcadian state is well
depicted in this painting.
And many people,
when they're shown a variety of
different landscapes if the
landscapes vary between the
highly dense urban environment
all the way to the wild
environment,
they prefer the pastoral,
the agrarian landscape.
The Consummation of
Empire is the next slide in
the series, the urban setting.
And I also have had a
fascination with urban areas and
have lived in Philadelphia,
I've lived in New Haven,
I've lived in Sao Paula in
Brazil and in San Francisco,
and eventually settled here in
Connecticut.
But it's this juxtaposition
that I find so interesting,
a love for the wild as well as
a love for a vibrant,
urban core.
And what happens in between in
terms of suburban sprawl will
become central to several of the
cases that we look at.
Cole then went on to think
about what happens if markets
are completely unregulated --
destruction, damage.
So we'll spend a good amount of
time thinking about how to
predict damage and how important
this is in the structure of
environmental standards.
And then desolation.
And many today have this image
of desolation 100,200 years down
the road in response to global
climate change.
So really, this set of
paintings structured my thinking
in a variety of different ways.
It made me wonder about what
the potential of law is.
What capacity do we have to
understand serious threats to
the environment and to human
health, particularly over long
periods of time?
What demands on science does
that make?
And how can we use law to
effectively reshape human
behavior in a way that would be
more sensitive,
that would ensure that when we
have twelve billion people in
the world that we will have
adequate food supplies,
we will have sufficient water,
it will be equitably
distributed,
we will have clean air,
and children,
grandchildren,
future generations will have an
environment that they can be
proud of.
I am certainly not proud of the
environment that my generation
is leaving to your generation.
And that really is,
that's the reason that I'm
standing here in front of you
today.
I've decided in my career that
rather than working for
government,
rather than working in the
private sector,
that I would spend my life,
the bulk of my career,
training future leaders,
whether or not you move on into
the public sector or the private
sector,
nonprofit world,
to think, I hope,
differently about environmental
quality and how you might shape
it.
So the central questions here
that we'll be looking at,
what's our capacity to manage
environmental quality?
What role has and could law
play in determining the future
of environmental quality?
And what's worked well,
what's failed,
and why?
If we can't answer these
questions,
I would hazard to say that we
don't have much hope of making a
dent in the kinds of problems
that we'll be facing over the
next century.
So the problems considered in
the course,
national security,
land use, food safety,
plastics, green building,
pesticides,
air pollution,
tobacco, wild lands,
national parks,
coastal development,
conservation policies,
urban and suburban growth,
transport energy,
and drinking water.
In my mind, what's worked well
and why?
Well, the nuclear weapons
history I think is quite
fascinating.
There are some wonderful
lessons there about how we used
state-of-the-art science in the
1950s to recognize a serious
threat to human health and how
we intervened and eventually how
John F.
Kennedy decided to ban the use
of testing of nuclear weapons in
the atmosphere that was
resulting in strontium-90 in the
bones at high concentrations,
particularly among the
youngest, the children.
Population control has been a
success.
Compared to the projections of
the 1970s by Paul Ehrlich and
Julian Simon and others,
it's quite striking that the
geometric projections have
diminished substantially,
particularly in developing
parts of the world.
The phase-out of chlorinated
hydrocarbons,
including DDT and aldrin and
chlordane and dieldrin,
heptachlor back in the 1970s.
These became one of the very
first targets of the
Environmental Protection Agency.
And because they are fat
loving, they're lipophilic,
they persisted,
they moved through the food
chain.
They moved into our bodies.
And you and I are still
carrying around residues of many
of these chlorinated
hydrocarbons.
Your concentrations are lower
than mine are.
But your concentrations
predominately came from your
mother via breast milk.
That's the mechanism of
transfer across generations for
some of these compounds.
So phasing them out was a very
important thing to do.
Lead in gasoline and paint were
phased out as well.
Chlorinated fluorocarbons that
were and are responsible for
diminishing the ozone layer that
exists in the upper
stratosphere,
so that reducing CFCs and
similar ozone-gobbling compounds
has been a success story,
at least the rate of loss has
been stabilized.
Polychlorinated biphenyl
reduction,
these are chemicals originally
thought to be beneficial because
they acted as a refrigerant and
flame retardant for electronic
technologies,
such as electrical transformers.
So that phasing out PCBs that
were building up in the tissues
of wildlife,
particularly large mammals,
as well as birds,
and also in human tissues,
has been a very important
success story.
Recognizing the threat of
asbestos in producing a very
rare form of cancer called
mesothelioma was a very
important step,
as well as the increasing
restriction on tobacco,
so that we're seeing a decline
in some forms of lung cancer in
response to the tobacco
restrictions.
And we're also seeing very
interesting declines in the rate
of addiction in those parts of
the country where advertising
has been most heavily restricted
and public service campaigns
have been mounted to warn people
about the dangers of tobacco.
We've also made some great
strides in the area of food
safety, particularly in terms of
reducing microbial
contamination.
And also, the stellar success
story about the rise of organic
food I think is something to
take note of and to learn from.
So what are the most persistent
problems, the ones that have
been hardest to deal with,
and why?
Fossil fuel consumption,
renewable energy innovation in
part due to our lack of
subsidies relative to
subsidizing fossil fuels as well
as nuclear power.
Radioactive materials,
the concentration of
radioactive materials,
particularly for the production
of weapons,
has created some of the most
hazardous sites in the world.
So Hanford, Washington,
the Hanford Works in
Washington,
as well as the Oakridge
Laboratory or Savannah River in
Georgia,
these are seriously
contaminated sites.
Waste management has also been
a persistent problem.
Our recycling efforts have
clearly failed us.
Most people don't know the
difference between a plastic
that is stamped with a number
six and a plastic that is
stamped with a number three.
And in fact,
I'll challenge you right now to
go through one week of this term
without buying any plastic.
And if anybody is capable of
doing that by the end of the
term, I will take you out for
lunch.
I've made that offer for the
past five years and I have not
spent one dime on lunch as a
result.
Transport, personal transport
as opposed to public transit
facilities, is a persistent and
growing problem.
We now have one vehicle in the
United States for every person
who is eligible to drive.
That's nearly 250 million
vehicles.
We have more vehicles per
capita in the United States than
any other place in the world.
And we drive more miles per
person than any place in the
world.
The failure to develop public
transit facilities is quite
striking.
Parks and protected areas,
we are not protecting areas the
way that we were back in the
1970s and the 1980s.
So why have we slowed down?
Why was the government in the
process of acquiring lands in
the 1960s, '70s,
and '80s and building parks and
building large corridors for
wildlife?
To conserve biological
diversity, but also to provide
wide-scale recreational
opportunities.
So why have land acquisition
efforts been stalled?
Biological diversity loss is
also growing,
in part because of the chemical
threats that I described earlier
in the lecture.
There are nearly 450 million
acres of the United States
landscape that are routinely
sprayed by biocides,
pesticides of one sort or
another.
There are 1,000 different
biocides that are each licensed
independently.
So at that scale,
how could we not think that we
would be threatening different
species?
Also agriculture.
One of the great drivers of
loss of biological diversity in
the world is agricultural
development.
And you can see this in the
Amazon,
where tropical rain forests
that are some of the richest and
most biologically diverse
ecosystems in the world are
being ripped up and planted with
soybeans for either food or fuel
production.
So we'll take a look at some of
the key drivers behind
biodiversity laws.
Marine species exploitation,
we'll take a look at the
decline of a variety of
commercial fish.
We'll also be taking a look at
the tendency of large predatory
fish to absorb mercury.
So mercury is emitted from
power plants.
It's also emitted from
incinerators.
It goes into global circulation
just like DDT would.
It also rains down on the earth
and it bio-accumulates in large
predatory fish.
By the end of the term,
you'll understand which fish
are safe and which are not,
and why.
And you'll also question the
Bush administration's decision
to lighten the regulation on
mercury emissions and how
dangerous that has become,
particularly for the youngest
in society.
We'll take a look at indoor air
quality.
And one aspect of this issue
that I'm quite interested in is
the Environmental Protection
Agency spends probably
ninety-five to ninety-eight
percent of its time and budget
thinking about the environment
as being the outdoor
environment.
Whereas we in the United States
now spend on average more than
ninety percent of our time
indoors.
And as somebody that is a dad
and cares about the future of
the environment and human
health, that's got me worried.
People are spending less time
outside.
They're experiencing nature at
a lower rate than ever before.
They are spending more time in
front of computers in indoor
environments than ever before.
And EPA does not do much to
regulate the environmental
quality of indoor environments.
So the reasons for that are
sometimes obvious and sometimes
not.
One clearly is a respect for
privacy and private property
rights.
But it means that anybody is
allowed to carry chemicals into
the indoor environment,
including cleansers or
pesticides or plastics that can
get into their bodies.
And there is basically no
regulation to prevent that.
Hazardous sites,
the number of hazardous sites
now in the United States is more
than 350,000 on EPA's list.
There are 50,000 different
hazardous sites that have been
severely contaminated that are
under the jurisdiction,
meaning the responsibility,
of the Department of Defense,
the Department of Energy,
and the Department of the
Interior.
There are 340,000 sites that
are owned in the private sector
that have been classified by EPA
as hazardous.
So the rate of cleanup of these
sites is not even one percent of
the rate of discovery of new
hazardous sites.
So this problem of basically
disregarding the chemical abuse
of the landscape,
feeling comfortable to throw
chemical mixtures out the back
door without concern for their
persistence and movement,
this is something that your
generation will have to deal
with.
Product labeling will also be a
subject that we'll take on.
Basically, if you look
carefully at product labels,
you'll see claims of product
effectiveness,
product appeal associated with
color or functionality.
You will not see much in the
way of claims or a demonstration
of hazard or guidance about how
you might manage the hazards.
So that product labeling could
be an effective way of conveying
information to the public,
to inform consumers to make
choices that are more
responsible.
So how should we adjust product
labeling law in a way that makes
sense?
I asked this question with
respect to pesticides several
years ago and found something
quite interesting.
If you look at a pesticide bag,
for example a fertilizer bag in
say a Home Depot.
You'll see the green lawn with
the children playing on the lawn
and bright colors on the front
of the bag.
And then the back of the bag in
print that may be eight point,
it may be six point in size,
print that I have to take my
glasses off and get very close
to be able to read.
The warnings are illegible and
unintelligible to a very large
proportion of society.
And there are some twelve
percent of the U.S.
population, not an
insignificant number in a
population of 310 million
people.
So ten percent that have no
capacity to read type that is
less than ten point in font.
That means that those warning
labels could never be effective
for that population.
If you add on to that
percentage, the group that is
illiterate,
the group that does not have
enough education in order to
understand what the risk is and
how they might manage the risk,
gradually, you get up to a
percentage that's close to forty
percent of the U.S.
population does not have the
capacity to understand a message
of hazard or the capacity to
interpret how to manage that
hazard in a way that would cause
the environment to be protected
or human health to be protected.
So the statutes we'll look at,
I'm not going to go through all
of these now,
but we'll go through the major
statutes and the book.
Weinberg and Reilly will give
you a very concise,
quick overview of the key
provisions of these statutes.
And I will show you how the
statutes apply individually to
the various cases.
We'll take a look,
not just at the chemical
management statutes,
but also the federal land and
resource management statutes,
such as the Wilderness Act,
the Endangered Species Act,
the National Park Service
Organic Act,
and several others.
Additional crucial statutes
that you might not think about
as being environmental in nature
include patent law,
governing trade secrecy,
the Freedom of Information Act
that gives you the right to
request from the government
information about public policy
or about the environment.
I'll pause here and just ask
how many of you have made
requests under the Freedom of
Information Act to a government
agency?
That's very interesting.
The majority of people that do
that in society are highly
specialized.
They work in the private sector
or they are lawyers,
they're using them as the basis
for lawsuits.
So the Freedom of Information
Act was intended to democratize
information that was held inside
libraries and government
agencies.
But it's been highly
ineffective in a variety of
ways.
The National Security Act,
the War Powers Act,
the Administrative Procedures
Act, Homeland Security,
the Patriot Act,
and different budget statutes,
ranging from subsidies to
authorizations for funding for
EPA.
And these statutes are
absolutely crucial.
So you can imagine a law being
passed, that -- let's say the
law had the intent to protect
the environment from a new
plastic compound.
So that law might be passed and
it might demand that the
chemical be tested thoroughly.
It might demand that it be
labeled in a way that would
ensure that it would be managed
more effectively.
It might assign penalties for
deviance.
But in Congress,
if Congress doesn't allocate
the money to EPA,
the program will fail.
So the industry recognizes this
quite clearly,
that they have not lost the
battle if a law is passed.
They will have an opportunity
year after year to go back to
Congress and try to block
allocation for monitoring that
issue, for enforcing that issue.
And that explains a lot of the
ineffectiveness of twentieth
century environmental law.
So on Thursday,
we'll come back to a discussion
about different types of
strategies to protect the
environment,
different decision standards
that are embedded in different
statutes.
And we'll particularly take up
this issue of distributional
effects.
How some chemicals behave
differently than others,
they result in exposures to
some groups that are higher than
others.
And also thinking about how
costs as well as benefits are
allocated quite differently in
society by environmental laws.
So I'm going to pause there and
just take a couple of minutes
for any questions that you've
got.
Yes?
Student:
>
Prof: Could you repeat
that please?
Student:
>
Prof: Yes.
After the lecture each day,
the lecture slides will be
posted online.
Also, I will use the Classes
server quite regularly.
Some of the readings that you
will have assigned to you will
be on the Classes server,
so that some of the discussion
sections as well may use
strategies to pose questions and
I'll require your responses on
the Classes server as well.
Yes?
Student:  And will you
hold office hours?
Prof: Will I hold office
hours?
I will hold office hours,
and I will announce those on
Thursday.
Student:  Okay.
Prof: Anything else?
Well thank you very much for
joining me.